hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we're I'm going to be talking about you
know an orderflow trading strategy
called stopping volume and you know it's
more than just reading what's taking
place in the orderflow I'm also going to
talk about um you know what is a good
chart type to use and you know the
answer is probably going to surprise you
but before I jump in if you've been
enjoying my videos be sure to subscribe
to the channel click the notification
Bell so you don't miss any new uploads
that I make and if you find this video
helpful be sure to hit the like button
for me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway you know I love hearing
your feedback all right so let's go and
talk about today's subject now you know
a question that I get a lot
is well it's really two parts what is
the best Market to trade and what is the
best chart type to trade um really you
could choose a lot of there's so many
different Futures markets out there
there's about 40 50 in the US that you
know trade decent enough volume that you
can can trade and and to be honest you
can trade um you know even once you get
a bit of experience you know you can
trade some of the more uh I don't want
to say ill liquid markets because you
know markets like um some of the
agriculturals you know there is decent
volume that you can trade and then you
know it sort of splinters off into the
next question well what's the best chart
type because you know in the past I used
to use a lot of range-based charts and
now I use a lot of time based charts
that doesn't mean one is better than the
other you know as a Trader you um evolve
you want to put the order flow
in a format that is easy for you to make
sense of what you're looking at right
there's no point of looking at the
orderflow on a chart that you're going
to struggle with right so that's why you
know sometimes I I talk about range
based charts sometimes I talk about time
based charts even tick based and volume
based charts but really the main charts
you're going to want to use is most
likely going to be um time based charts
or range based charts and now that's not
to say you can't use a ranco chart again
it's all about putting the order flow
right the data that you're getting from
the market from The Exchange into an
easyto read format okay and you know the
strategy I'm going to talk about today
is called stopping volume right and
really what is stopping volume it's just
heavy volume coming in at the end of a
move either a move up or a move down
basically you know stopping the market
from dropping any further right it hits
its floor there's a big bid down there
there's passive buyers waiting there if
it was a move up you know be big sellers
up near a high and today in the e- minis
um there's a great example of this and
uh let's just go back to it
here okay so it came in around 10 this
morning all right let me get the
Crosshair is up here for you right and
you can see this is a uh one minute
chart okay and it's coming in at
5092 and a half and and what is stopping
volume okay well the first time we trade
here in this bar at 11 at 10:14 11
contracts trade okay we bounce up a tick
next Bar opens up comes down you so
basically it's trading two and a half 2
and
3/4 2 and 3/4 offered at at o or 93 even
um and there's a big bidder down here
how do I know it's a bidder well by
looking at the volume I see it's coming
in on the bid side so I know you have
aggressive sellers selling into that so
it's actually you know 11 plus 997
that's what a,
18 contracts there so basically just
over a th000 contracts now how do I know
this is stopping volume well one I
understand this Market I know what heavy
volume is especially on a minute based
chart you know I can see you know 997
just you know again you don't have to
sit here and and make notes and say is
this heavy or not you know and right I
could just look at the recent trading
that's going on I don't see anything
really that strong you know here's 700
here's 800 um or I think earlier we had
95 here so 900 close to 1,000 is pretty
strong okay
Market in this bar started to Rally up
you know we did hit 900
here then it went offer there right you
can see the 539 traded there okay
stopping volume stops a move basically
okay that's what you got to think of
when you think of stopping volume now
how can you tell really easily where's
the point of control in the bar okay
well
normally point of control in the bar is
going to be somewhere in the middle
right when you think
of you know the standard deviation of
how volume is distributed throughout the
bar it's going to be somewhere in the
middle because you've had plenty of time
to trade in each bar and you'll notice
you know most of the bars it's somewhere
near the middle okay but when I have a
green bar and I have the volume the
heaviest volume meaning the point of
control at the bottom of the bar and the
market reverses to me that's a clear
sign L of stopping volume you see the
market got a nice rally off of this and
again it comes down to understanding 997
at the end of the move is a strong sign
of stopping volume now this is a minute
base chart and sort of getting back to
the other uh chart types right because
you could also use um you know a time
based this is a Time based chart you
could use a uh tick base chart so let me
just uh grab one here for you just give
me a
seconds
whoops there we go try to move my uh
recorder um you can see down here right
now this is a range based chart so it's
based on price movement and right down
here let me get the crosshairs up on
here you see a
108 okay so my math was off I thought it
was 10 18 anyway you can see down here
108 Market's reversed now the point of
control is not on the bottom of this bar
it's actually here because you got 466
and 593 you had those two numbers it's
bigger than just 108 but usually when
you see stopping volume right it's going
to be all on one side at the bottom of
the bar you know 108 right here and it's
going to come after a move you know here
eight is that a stopping volume no you
know people say what about this 102 no
it's not at the end of the move this is
the move right we just sold off um you
that was a 10 14 1015 you know 950 we
were trading 5112 and 3/4 we sell off um
you know 20 points and boom it stops
that is what stopping volume is and
again stopping volume is not something
you see happen left and right in the
market right it's understanding it's
it's a above average volume going
through at the end of the move right
because normally what happens is you get
to ends of moves and you know volume
just sort of Peters out Peters out but
there was still some strong selling you
can see we're coming into this low we
coming in pretty hot a lot of selling
imbalances you know that's those red
numbers in the footprint even here this
Bar's got 1 2 3 4 five six sellum
balances followed by another one 2 three
so there is strong selling you see the
Delta's you know 907 300 and then it
just it just ends right here because you
have strong passive buyers basically
absorbing whatever aggressive selling is
taking place now again you know getting
back to the Chart types it doesn't
matter if you're using a minute based
chart or a range based chart what
matters is that you're able to take that
information that the market
is generating you know Traders are
generated in the market with they buying
and selling and putting it into an
easyto read
format okay so you know if I was looking
at a time based chart I could have
picked it up but it was a little bit
easier easier to see it on a range based
chart okay because on the time based
chart it's kind of split out in this
case you know over two bars one and
two whereas on the Range based chart
it's just on the one bar okay but again
you still see that 997 the point of
control on the bottom of the bar that
stands out as well and you know what was
interesting on the time based chart
which you don't
see on the Range based chart I mean you
have this one big bar here strong
negative Delta
1140 but on
the Range base chart we're coming in you
see we got that nice we hit that low
then we start
rallying as you're coming in you're kind
of coming in hot -
97 Delta -
304 - 162 so was coming in strong then
weaker weaker here right cuz look here
on this big selling it's all- 11100 -
900 -200 - 800 - 700 then Delta's kind
of mixed and then the Delta picks up
again - 900 and you're thinking oh my
God am I going to see a repeat of what I
just saw here with the strong selling
it's 304 okay it's not light by any
means then you hit minus 162 so you
should be already be thinking by looking
at this if you're looking at a range
based chart - 97 - 304 - 162 then
actually turns positive here 399
okay aggressive selling less aggressive
selling lesser aggressive selling
aggressive
buying all right that you can see on the
Range based chart that on the time based
chart you you just don't see it there
now you do have you can see the
aggressive buying picking up here so you
had the strong negative Delta minus 1140
then a positive Delta 221 not overly
strong it's decent then it grows a bit
more 343 359 so so it's getting a little
bit stronger over subsequent bars right
especially after you had that big
aggressive selling taking place here
right and you know that would have me
worried you got very strong selling and
we can't go any lower just as you know
over here we had very strong aggressive
selling -400 Delta here- 1496 this one
just went sideways this one continued
right in the next
bar so if anything you get this strong
negative Delta then you're just sort of
going sideways you know maybe there's
going to be some more aggressive selling
coming in here this bar had minus 54
554 but it couldn't go any lower and we
just started rallying up from there but
you saw some signs here early of some
aggressive buying coming in so what
you're looking at actually between the
two different charts you can see here
the aggressive selling just sort of
getting
weaker than the aggressive buying coming
in but if you're looking at a a timebase
chart you don't notice that the
aggressive selling is getting weaker all
you see is is this one bar with strong
negative
Delta and then you start to see the
aggressive buying creep in here okay so
again it's different ways to look at the
market if you're looking at a time based
chart you notice one thing right with
the aggressive buying coming in if
you're looking at a range based chart
you're noticing that aggressive selling
is coming in now ideally it'd be great
if you could you know if there was one
chart that would show both of those
things but you know the charts are
created different ly based off of um
different methods of plotting data right
time based charts is just goes by time
right after you know this is a minute
based chart after 60 seconds boom a new
bar is going to form whereas range-based
you know deals with price movements
right it doesn't take into account time
doesn't take into account volume it
takes into account how price is moving
okay to form new bars so there's no
right or wrong chart type you know I I
know guys that use ranco charts I don't
personally but they're successful with
it so who am I to say n you can't use
that you know if you have a chart that
you use that helps you understand the
market that you're looking at by all
means use it all right everyone that's
going to end this video again if you
haven't already be sure to hit the
Subscribe button you know we like to get
this Channel Growing and uh keep going
from there so have a great rest of your
day everyone take
care